je vous souhaite la bienvenue pour cette
séance qui est une séance importante
puisque le débat des orientations
budgétaires vous le savez reste un
moment fort pour la collectivité
départementale d'abord parce que c'est
le moment de réaffirmer pour les élus
que nous sommes le projet de mandature
le la volonté que nous avons d'être plus
près de la de la la réalité aise et et
et nous réaffirmons le projet qui a été
présenté à l'ensemble des élus à notre
administration à nos partenaires mais
aussi à la population réunionnaise sur
le projet de mandature avec les trois
les trois axes les trois piliers que
sont le développement humain le
développement territorial l'intelligence
institutionnelle nous revenons avec
d'autres élus de l'ADF plusieurs
départements n'ont plus la
possibilité de payer même le r ça hein
il y a des départements qui sont
totalement dans le rouge et le 3è
trimestre de l'année 2016 il y a
certains départements qui n'ont pas payé
le RSA sur les trois derniers mois de
l'année alors nous nous pouvons au fond
modestement mais avec fierté être se
dire qu'à la réunion nous avons maîtrisé
nos dépenses que nous payons le RSA que
nous assumons nos responsabilités et que
grâce à une bonne gestion des finances
publiques et je remercie et la Direction
des finances les services qui qui
travaillent sur le budget le
vice-président cy Mel qui a apporté
véritablement du travail tout au long de
l'année nous nous réussissons
effectivement à garder des marges de
manœuvre pour non seulement continuer à
assurer nos obligations mais également à
avoir la possibilité d'investir puisque
vous le verrez que dans le budget notre
investissement le budget
d'investissement est plutôt en essort et
non pas en
monsieur